okay
[Music]
earlier than normal
um apologies thank you chair apologies
from councilor Holmes right
nothing from you tell me no I haven't
heard
all right so the last meeting
everybody
what the minutes
very very after 20 minutes
apart from New Street Denver
it's which microphone
page four
um on the points underneath I just
wonder whether it should read to
investigate statutory activities as a
cost center rather than non-steps true
whether that be the correct whereabouts
is that so it's underneath it's the
bullet points it's the second bullet
point at the bottom of the page of page
four
which is Page Six yeah
um it means to investigate non-stage
activities as a cost center would
require separate exercise I think that
meant statutory rather than
non-statistry
um
I thought that Mr Harper at that time
had asked for non-statitude information
from the finance manager and then
um Steve had mentioned that actually it
would be quite a separate exercise to to
record that I thought that was a
discussion that was
um
underway when when we recorded that bit
of the minute
okay I I'll accept what you're saying I
think it would read better if it was
but it would take it as what was the
discussion if that's why
we can go back over the notes and yeah
and double check okay
um on page five that says page five top
or bottom oh page three at the top five
at the bottom it says about
[Music]
um
the uh what is that the standard of
Maintenance of great Torrington it's a
large area of 12 sites to maintain and
when they were inherited they were in
poor condition
says that that doesn't include
the three sites that the Town Council
maintained because they were in
excellent condition when they're
inherited it was just the delivery sites
that were in poor condition
right okay
that's noted into addressing okay we've
noted that okay
through the minutes
okay page one
phase two page three
page four and page five
proposal please
Duke and
your second bit Rachel okay fine
yeah I'm just waiting a minute yeah oh
can I vote now please
okay
action list page eight
have you got anything from Richard on
this
yeah the answer is
and let's check
oh yeah this was about the leaves I want
that
[Music]
so we can we can put that down as
complete
okay
right
out of four public contributions
okay
from five Declarations of Interest
your own situation with Declarations of
interest if you've got any please
because when when we get to the item
that you've got an interesting okay
item six agent matches brought for the
permission of the chair I haven't got
any uh urgent matters
agreements of agenda pass one and two
we've got no part two
right we're now on to item eight the
budget
and we are going to have
151 officer David
yeah to go for it mate okay okay
um I've got a presentation
um just before I start and go through
the presentation the report that's
almost sent out is essentially the same
report that went to your calories on
community and resources however at
community and resources there was a
separate report from Helen Smith who was
the council's planning manager so you
can approval to introduce
um charging for section 106 monitoring
and that was approved of community and
resources yeah so the figures in this
presentation differ ever so slightly
from the figures in your report because
of that recommendation essentially
outputs in fifty thousand pounds worth
of income from section 106 monitoring
for 23 24 and 75 000 for each subsequent
year as a medium-term financial strategy
so that's why the figures in the
presentation will differ from the
figures in your report and that's
because of retirement issue in terms of
the time okay so just and I'll when it
comes to the relevant point I'll point
that out
okay so what will my presentation cover
our recap where the council was this
time last year very brief refresher on
the sources of the council's finances
I'll talk about council tax I'll talk
about council tax support fund which is
a new government Initiative for 23.24
I'll briefly touch on the 23 24
provisional settlement which is actually
now final as of Easter day we get the
final figures no significant changes at
all
foreign
not flicking on
Tom
we'll move on to next slide time
we'll pass that
our failed at the first Toyota
why don't we figure out a technological
solution
that's right we'll have a recess
okay and I'll go through the business
route revaluation I'll talk about the
key assumptions I've made is set in both
the budget 23 24 and subsequent years of
the median term Financial strategy uh
summarize some risk and sensitivity so
house
sensitive the budgets are on some of the
assumptions of some of the assumptions
are incorrect I'll summarize what it
means for the 23 24 budget are also
summarize what this means over the
longer term uh we're going to
recommendations and next steps
next slide please Tom okay where were
you this time last year so back in
February 2022 we were forecasting
deficits there that's the blue
across the median term Financial
strategy so if you can see I was
forecasting that the deficit would Peak
into the financial year 2324 at just
about 600 000 I would only get back into
balance by 26 27 and that accumulative
deficit over the median median term
Financial strategy period which was up
to 26 27 would be 1.4 million pounds and
next slide please Tom
and I remember it's probably well aware
we have a reserve called the
transitioning Government funding
research or tgfr for short
and in very simple terms that's our very
new day firmed our building Society
accountants we use to balance the budget
so Bridge the gaps it's a bit like you
can
finances if you're struggling to pay
your bills one then you might tip into
your building Society just to balance
the books made you pay for a car repair
Etc so that's the balance that we're
predicting on the transition and
government funding Reserve so as you can
see we've started in 21 22 1.7 million
and we're forecasting about 26 27 to run
that down to just over a course a minute
278 000 pounds next filed please
so this is just a very brief recap
on the sauces of torridges funding so as
you can see there there's a pie chart
the biggest figure 39 is our fees and
charges
uh then it's followed by business rates
which is the red at 29 council tax at 25
and they actually direct central
government grants that's something so
if you compare storage as a district
council with say a unitary authorities
such as say Plymouth they'd have a far
higher percentage of their funding
coming from central government grants
because they've got social care and
Children's Services to fund next slide
please Tom
so just a little brief reminder in case
any members were unaware we are the
building authority at Terry so we
collect the council tax that's due
within turidge of course the vast
majority of the council tax we actually
collected on behalf of other people our
preceptors with Devon County receiving
over 72 of the council tax so
um the Red Bar there represents the
total charge for a Bandy the dark blue
is Devon County Council and I think
Williams have like a black color turret
you can see it's quite a small
percentage of the only that money's then
passed on to other preceptors next slide
please
um this slide is just showing that our
share of the transport Council has been
in long-term decline
so back in 1617 we were just under nine
percent of the total council tax
collected stayed within turret and now
that's going down to just over eight
percent and the main reason for that is
because of the referendum limits on
council tax which have been
five pound
uh three percent which I thought has
been greater
um five pound or three percent which
open greater so basically we've had
below inflation increasing on council
tax for several years the referendum for
23 24 is 2.99 next slide please
okay
so I just want to show what the impact
on this table of a 2.99 council tax
increase will be so council tax
um everyone's quoted in bandage but
obviously there's lots of different
bands at council tax from a to eight in
green a highlighted band a b and c and
that's just to show actually 68 of the
properties we're encourage are actually
in those bands they're in the lower
bands so the vast majority of people are
in bands a to c
have shown what the charges on those
bands for terrorist's share of the
council tax so a band days the economy's
119 pound and 11 Pence and then I've
shown the impact of a 2.9 increase on
council tax so on a Band-Aid that would
be three pound fifty six on a ban B four
pound fifteen and an unbalanced C for
power 75. so even on the Banshee the
weekly impact of our increase of council
taxes should be approved up 2.99 is only
nine pound nine Pence a week and that's
fine please
Right Far 23 24 central government has
brought in something called the council
tax support funding
and essentially what that is it's trying
to cap the cost of council tax increases
for those people in receipt of local
council tax support
the support is capped at 25 pounds per
household Towers has had funding
provided to a hundred and three thousand
pounds any funding left after capping
the increases for those in receipt of
local Council without support can be
used to support economically vulnerable
households I would anticipate probably
at least 50 000 would be available to
support economically vulnerable
households for most recipients and local
council tax support this essentially
means there will be no increase to their
council tax liability for 23.24 next
slide
I've just created a little table there
so I've taken a Banshee so as I've said
before
um or 68 of at the residents of tourism
in a band A to Z and I've shown the
left-hand column shows the charges for
the various entities Devon County
Council the police the fire
terrorize ourselves on The Potter's
councils and then I took what I think is
the projected increase in percentage I'm
expecting count it they're probably just
under five percent but it's basically
will be five percent dividend Cornwall
six point zero eight percent
difference from a set fire 5.4 our sales
2.99 so I will took an average for the
parish council for this
probably 40 of them to a precept and
it'll vary somewhere no increase
somewhere above increases so the net
colon 23 24 shows what the council tax
will be and it'll show that the increase
found all the different preceptors if
you go over you see a figure of
94.87 however for somebody in receipt of
local council tax support
if you get the full support that is 75
support towards their bill they're
currently only paying 476 pounds 65
which would go up to just over 500
pounds which would actually be an
increase of 23 pounds 72. and given that
we can cap any increase by maximum to 25
pounds they would get essentially that
increase negated to zero
um so at the bottom and read it says 80
of the recipients are local council tax
support received the full 75 so I can't
say definitively then nobody in receipt
of local council tax support won't see
some increase whether it be in very
small numbers anybody on local council
tax support will see any increase in
their council tax next slide please
okay so the 2023 central government
grant settlement
so just to put into Concepts one of the
earlier slides remember they only found
about seven percent of our income so
whilst it's important what we get from
central government it's not the biggest
um source of our funding that we have
so assignment was only for one year
the rural Services delivery Grant which
is our biggest Grant has not been
uplifted by inflation for the first
consecutive years actually today has
however
so if you bear with me
today I used to know they actually did
increase the rural Services delivery
Grant however there is a corresponding
reduction in US funding guarantee Grant
to the effect is that we're no better
off
terrific okay
questions during the presentation
that was my question regarding that
didn't we have the same not the same
problem but did we have a problem last
year about this particular Grant from
government that we were not uh
equally treated as other Shire counties
no the world service to delivery Grant
nationally has not gone up for three
years on the track that's right the same
for everybody the latest final
settlement shows rural service with
delivery Grant going up so I was quite
excited yesterday I thought we had an
extra 55 000 or they've done simply
reduced the funding guarantee a
corresponding amount
terrific
okay okay
sorry I was just going to ask um you
talk about council tax support how many
residents and storage get council tax
it's probably just under four thousand
there is a difference that you need to
be aware of there is that there's
probably about one thousand
1 600 of them of working age so the
maximum support they can get is 75
people are pensionable age can get full
100 support for a local council tax
support not every pensioner will give
some people have private pensions our
savings so it's a slightly different
across the council area about 4 000
individuals
okay yeah
um Sarah should have said to just
anybody else ask questions during the
presentation just
I'm happy to take them
so there was an introduction of a
funding guarantee event to ensure that
all councils receive at least a three
percent increase in their core spending
power and I'll come to that on the next
slide
the new home bonus was confirmed for 23
24 141
000 with no Legacy payments
just as a part of reference we used to
get 2 million for that in 26 to 2016
2017. The Refuge support that has been
uplifted by inflation and now
incorporates two previously separate
grants which is the council tax and its
Grant and the local council tax support
Administration Grant next slide please
okay so the chart below shows toes is
increasing his confluential spending
power which is abbreviated to CSP in
comparison to other sectors of local
government and inflation so what CSP is
is the income the council gets from
council tax retained business rates and
direct central government grant so it
ignores what we get from fees and
charges so what we've got there is a
chart so on the very left hand side in
blue is towards is increasing its
confidential spending power of 4.5 and
that compares with the the average for
Shire District similar councils to
ourselves at five percent
and a village bar charts in Gray as our
different sectors of the local Authority
sort of family and the the biggest
increase of 10.2 percent has been
Metropolitan districts so they're the
ones that have got adult social care and
Children Services the
orange line that goes across is
inflation
but when this was done in November was
10.7 and inflation is about right now
anyway so as you can see we've had a
significantly below
um inflation increase in our
comprehensive spending power and that is
this chart wasn't too dissimilar this
time last year obviously with inflation
not being as high next slide please
okay so
um from the 1st of April 2023 there's
been a revaluation of business rates so
all business at National have been
reassessed by the valuation office and
I've got new rateable values
we're in terror is the growth not
available
for business rates
our business sites and Renewables which
is 100 retained by turret has increased
to 711 000 pounds from 605 000 net slide
extensive range of support measures for
people affected by the business rate
re-evaluation so first of the most
important there's been no increase in
the multiplier so as a business you have
a rateable value
and then you pay a rate in the pound is
your charge for business rates the rate
in the chapel has not been changed for
four years now
Heritage is compensate for that lost
income the income we would have got have
gone up by inflation which are the rules
by a section 31 Grant
there's a 75 relief for all premises in
Leisure retail and Hospitality sector it
was 50
um in 23 22 23 and that's been capped at
110k for business so if you're in a pub
they'll reassess what your business
rates are they'll be a charge and then
it's the 75 release will be applied but
it's capped at 110 000 per business so
something like wetherspoons
we'll only get 110 000 pounds
and this transitional relief depending
on the variable value of 5 10 or 30
percent so that's really what that's
doing is your rateable value has gone up
because of the business rotary
evaluation but you don't jump straight
away to that new charge it's staggered
and the amount of um transitional relief
depends upon the rateable value
so we're a business no longer receives
small business or IE it's gone up the
business rates have gone up and it's
taken them out of the fresh air of the
small business route relief whatever it
goes up to their increase is capped at
600 pounds and that's why please
I'm sorry thank you you didn't remind me
does this apply to to Billy Joes with
the business rates
if you have a small business if you have
to prove to a small business right and
they would
if that complete service less small
business rates yeah
okay
yeah so you've got a chart there in
front of you
so that shows the budget for two the
budget for 2023 and the median term
Financial structure so very simpler the
blue line is our expenditure
the red line is our income
so as you can see for 23 24 remarkably
absolutely remarkably we're as good as
balanced
then there's quite a gap developed in 24
25. well that's for a variety of factors
one of the main reasons would be that we
did a reassessment of our business rate
appeals and that was a one-off
benefit to the council in 23-24 but
that's not there again in 24 25.
and then we narrow and then in 26 27 the
Gap kind of widens out again and that's
primarily because we're the cost show
agreement with Devon County Council
We're The Collection Authority for Waste
we were incentivized to collect
recycling that agreement ends in 26 27
that's 290 000 pounds per year to the
council so as we look that we come close
to balance but we're never balancing any
uh throughout the reading term Financial
strategy and that's why please
so going back just as a refresher
we have the transition in Government
funding reserve the building Society
account the rainy day fund whatever
description works for you which what we
tip we tip
we go into to balance the budgets when
we've got a gap and the the white line
there shows where I'm at forecasting the
balance on that should be and as you can
see we don't really use it in the first
year because we've got balance but we go
down by the end at 27-28 and we're
forecasting the balance is going to be
under half a million pounds so it is
it's not great but it's also not
disastrous as we stand next slide please
so what key assumptions have I done in
setting both the budgets for 23 24 and
further reading term Financial strategy
and I'm assumed that members will
increase the council tax by the current
referendum limit of 2.99 which obviously
still significantly below inflation the
settlement I got so the council got for
23 24 is a one-year settlement
so I voluntler assumed the value of
23.24 settlement over the lie for the
median term Financial strategy I'm not
done that entirely because I know that
the revenue support program will grow up
by inflation but in essence that's where
I've done there's no guarantee that will
be the case
base of the Council of 1.5
and where planning applications we
receive for renewable energy schemes and
estimated the additional business rate
income due has been included in the
medium term financial and if I recall I
think I've put the figures in the report
so I've made some assumption about some
additional growth over and above the 1.5
business rate income that's now please
um income from treasury deposits
I've assumed
um interest rates will be three percent
over the life of the mtff now currently
they're actually four percent
and I've also made some assumptions
reduced income as the council starts to
spend its capital reserves on projects
such as the environment Center and the
maritime Innovation Center in Apple
store and just to give a little bit of
context when I sat here this time last
year interest rates were half a percent
so they got an eight-fold in 12 months
so it's been volatile
income infusing charges I've made some
various assumptions just in terms of
basically the income we get this year's
assume for the subsequent years
and we're planning income I think it's
in the report
the last three years have been quite
exceptional the 20 21 20 21 20 I think
are both topped one million pounds it's
just come down a little bit from those
highs in The Current financial year
service
790 per annum however none just need to
be aware is that prior to the pandemic
our planning income was near a 550 to
600 000.
employer contributions the council makes
a is going to make contributions in 19.5
percent over the life of the mtfso for
every 100 pound an employee earns the
council puts 19.50 into their pension
pot and I've assumed that that rate will
continue over the life of the medium
term Financial strategy but the next one
due is
2026-27 so it could change but I've not
made any assumption about it
and I've also assumed that we're paying
an underlying 20 grand extra per year to
the underlying pension deficit next
slide
um
I've assume to pay a world of five
percent for 23 24 of the per award
for the council in the coming year 22 23
averaged about seven percent the unions
are actually put in a per world of RPI
plus two percent
I don't know so kind of assumed a
payroll to two percent for the remainder
of the meetings and financial on the
basis of inflation will return as the
government says to more and more and
more levels
I've also assumed that the current level
expenditure and temporary accommodation
Remains the Same at 1.3 million pounds
per annum
so I've not made any assumptions about
as we've been able to bring that down
over the life of the medium-term
financial strategy that's right please
okay
so
I've talked to you about my assumptions
but there's one guarantee is that any of
those assumptions that they're going to
be wrong I don't know what the payroll
world will be I will get that wrong
because it's not for me to make that
judgment that they're done on a national
basis
interest rates will change
inflation or change
so I've just gone through the next few
slides just some assumptions some risk
and shows how the figures can change if
some of the assumptions are wrong and
how it doesn't say too much on an
assumption to be incorrect to make a
reasonable big impact on the council's
finances next slide please
so what would happen if we didn't
increase the council tax in 23-24.
so as you can because there's not sure
that cost is 132 000 pounds and that
would grow to 156 000 by 2728 so the
blue
is where we are we're in prediction
the red is how much worse that would be
if we just didn't increase the calcium
just for one year just for 23.24 much
live please Tom
yeah and this one but it's more Stark
when you look at the impact on the
transition Government funding reserve
the rainy day fund the urban South
Dakota so if you recall I was projecting
a balance of 494 000 that's the blue
line
but by simply now increasing the council
tax for one year for 23.24
the balance on the transitioning
government fund is the red line as you
can see it goes into deficit of
basically
300 million by 2728
so it's quite a standard difference over
700 000 pounds Difference by just the
decision made in one year the next slide
please
so what I've done there is I've modeled
if I get the payroll back Wrong by one
percent for 23 24 and 24.25
so the blue line again that says having
the balance on the transitioning
Furniture the red line shows how the
deficit that would would go into deficit
on the transition Government funding
research so quite a small change in the
assumptions about the power wall can
make quite a big difference and leave
the council in an overdrive position at
a future point in time
and again
okay
I've assumed your interest rates will be
three percent of the duration of mtfs I
clearly didn't update my presentation
for the latest Bank of England
announcement so they're currently four
percent four percent not three and a
half percent
it is correct that there were 9.5 back
in February 2022.
so it's an increase of eight-fold not
Sevenfold over the last 12 months just
so you know a one percent movement in
interest rates up or down
means over 125 000 less income of 125
more income the converse of that is that
when we borrow money
for us particularly the environment
Center and some borrowing that we need
to take for the maritime Innovation
Center the interest interest rate is the
Converse that in terms of as interest
rate goals that costs us more to borrow
um
so as I said I've largely used 23 24
Grand salmon from government as a basis
for estimating Grant income for the
duration the median term Financial
strategy well the government has
announced a fair funding will be
undertaken at the start of the next
Parliament
and given that Shire districts like
turret have benefited Mulch and retain
business rates some redistribution are
funding across local authorities and
sectors is to be expected so when they
brought in business rate retention
40 of the business rates our colleagues
at Devon County only keep nine percent
and I think when they originally come
introduce that they didn't want
vulnerable services like Social Services
being
um subject to veganism business rate
income as it's turned out
um out from which every shower district
has benefited from growth in its
underlying business rates
so I think when the Nets redo this
there'll be some redistribution I don't
know what transitional Arrangements will
be in place
okay so I'm just saying that so that's a
risk
the next slide please okay so looking
forward
um
a little bit of a mood Hoover at times
but I'm actually saying this is a
largely positive
and financial position the council has
given where we could be and lots of
other councils are in
however the significant assumptions
if only the interest rates were probably
sat in probably in the city
um earning a greater pay
yeah perhaps as much as going maybe yeah
so we can easily see that some of the
assumptions can easily tip us into a
different position
and we still requests on the immediate
action to try and bring the budgets back
into balancing that's why we're
recommended in member budget working
continues its work next slide please
so there's two things that are actively
on the horizon one is we're trying to
prevent Leisure provide that to
terrorists looking to explore external
grant funding up what options to
increase the Energy Efficiency across
the council's larger facilities the
actual Leisure facilities are the
greatest use of gas electric that the
council have and that understandable
we've got swimming pools and they're out
of operation
and the council continues to employ
opportunity to secure additional hostile
accommodation in order to meet the
challenges faced by the current housing
currency in very simple terms
hostels Savers money on temporary
accommodation and generate an income to
the council so
the more hostile accommodation who have
you know in fact purely Financial
standpoint is good it's not ideal we
could obviously an idea that the people
would be actually insustainable
properties houses and flats rather than
in the Hostile accommodation next time
please so so at this table charity so
the top half of the technical shown
where the medium term Financial strategy
is at the moment so
so you've got the funding Gap and the
utilization the transition Government
funding reserves so as you say five only
you expecting to take five thousand
pounds out of the transition Government
funding reserve for 23.24.
and then it rises to 357 and then by the
end of the period it's um 147. so
accumulative we would have used 860 000
of our transition government fundraiser
which would leave us a balance of 494
000 that's the figure in blue towards
the top on the right hand side however
if we can generate some savings from the
Leisure sector about Energy Efficiency
and from hostile accommodation and I'm
forecasting there when they're up and
run into 70 and 90 respectively if you
look at the allow the Nets to bottom
line it says revised subtitles funding
Gap if you look at 2728 that's minus 40.
that essentially means the council is
back in the black so to speak with
balanced
and if that was the case and they came
to pass we would then be using 255 000
of the transition and government funding
reserve and we still have a balance on
that transition Government funding
reserve a 1.1 Million by 27.28.
and that's loud please
so the recommendations to full Council
terrorage Bandy council tax increase by
2.99 from 178.66 to 184 pounds of zapper
the net revenue budget is
11.155 million and the council's
contribution to reserves is outlined of
paragraph 11.4 of the report are
approved and in light of the Council of
finances identified report the number of
budget working group should continuous
work within the council's budgets back
into balance in that slide
there wasn't on that slide I thought it
was just questioned I think it just says
questions
about his working group I noticed what
we all do all the time is sort of
increasing fees around the council
um shouldn't we've been looking exactly
what Steve raised earlier on about what
what is our statutory requirements and
what is the what is that funding and
that's the base level now we work from
that as opposed to trying to increase
fees all the time
to make some comments obviously when the
working group was established it would
want you to look at in the first
instance and concentrate particularly on
areas that didn't involve redundancies
or cuts and services which is which it's
primarily done and you're right it
focused on on fees and charges now
clearly when you start looking at
statutory Services other services you
really need to be looking at the
council's Strategic plan and whether the
council should be once or should be
going in in a different direction so
ultimately rather than just looking at
those the council as a whole should be
looking at its direction of travel first
rather than
just starting to look at the services
that underline them
um and obviously as we come into an
election period we'll have a new Council
uh very shortly and one of the first
roles of that new Council will be
looking at its strategic priorities and
what the underpins are like the
financial strategies and other
strategies so
um I think that's why David's uh
reflected the report of the budget
working group continue because there are
challenges and that will kind of work in
tandem if you like with the new council
with a new strategic plan
okay do you want to add anything yeah
um and just before well we'll go back a
couple of months we've done most of the
hard work on looking at what we could
actually
lift without cutting services at all you
know most of our charges are lower than
many of our neighbors so we looked at
that
but we did stop looking at whether we
need to be harder and I did ask
um David that we we've got this these
figures so that you all know where we
are
you know what discussion
I think as a council
mindfully then if somebody works in the
community quite a lot it's
we have a duty to our members of our
communities to
if we did that
serious issue
okay at the moment
slightly better
um
Global Services on Monday I was on an
RGA meeting yesterday when we were doing
all this what was
the score you haven't spoken system we
probably won't my disappointment there
was our figure is quite lower than many
of our corresponding
and that is partly because we've got
provided
so that's a double of one million ways
by paying him to build enough
and there is a wrong trade of reasons
why we haven't
foreign
um which has been very positive
and I think it's gone quite well
750 Services
you know
tourism and they're charging more a
tourists
but of course they
have other questions
Where We Are
thank you thank you
anybody want to ask him a question
okay just an observation no it's just an
observation the the member budget
working group category on the tourist
private doesn't have any papers in it
the the member budget working group
folder doesn't have any papers in it
on the private toys private I would
assume that's because it's a working
group
all right well we've got we've got the
recommendations here in front of do we
endorse these recommendations yeah well
proposal
Rachel seconded
thank you
yeah just about one yeah
good good morning councilors good
morning officers um so I'm going to do a
update of the capital program
um for 23 24 in the next five years next
slide please
so the capital program covers the next
five years it consists of our approved
projects which we refer to as pids and
these are all funded by
um reserves contributions from revenue
Capital receipts or grants or a
combination of of all four so the
capital program brought forward at the
start of the year we had roughly 26
million pound program and funding of 28
and a half leaving us a surplus of two
and a half million next slide please
um so the some of the pressures the
program's under as David mentioned in
his previous presentation the new homes
bonus 50 of this used to be allocated to
Capital and this is in sharp decline so
we get much less funding in for Capital
purposes and we've also the program is
under inflation pressures so we've got
significant increases inflation which
hits all aspects of the project all
projects really so for example the
environment Center project was adjusted
back in December 2022 by full Council
just to reflect these soil pressures
next slide please
um so this is normally the point where
we would add new heads to the program
but due to the funding pressures and
inflation pressures were under
um we didn't seek any new pids for the
2324 program
now with that in mind there are some
additional projects which arose during
the year and these are to alleviate some
of the wider cost pressures that the
council's under these were Sully house
and Sully house modular units these were
both approved by CNR and back in March
22 and the hubblestone conversion which
is also approved by CNR back in July
2022 next slide please Tom so
so here just taking you through the
updates to the program
um during the year so we've got the
brought forward of 26 million then we've
updated it for the environment Center
which has brought it down slightly
and then if we add these um projects in
at the homelessness projects then you go
back up to 26 million and our Surplus
changes to 1.5 million
and then we also extend the program for
another year to update it for the full
five-year period so this takes it back
up to 27 million pound program with 29
million pound
funding which gives us 2.2 million
pounds of surplus
now at this point that 2.2 million pound
Surplus can be a bit misleading because
the program also within the capital
program we have the vehicle program and
for the vehicle program we use this to
refresh our larger Fleet so we've
extended this to fund the vehicle
program all the way to 32.33
and what that means is we're saving up
really to buy that next Fleet so
actually some of that Surplus when we're
looking at the five years is actually
savings to buy the next the fleet up in
3233 so the bottom part of the slide
there is where I've split the program
into the vehicle program and and the
rest really so shows that the rest
really is a our other projects outside
the vehicles we've got 22 million pounds
and 22 and a half of funding which is so
roughly so it gives us roughly a 900 000
pound Surplus which is much much smaller
next slide please
so with that 900
000 pound Subs in mind actually the
program's under
some pressures going forwards to take
into consideration so we've got Leisure
with the three Center centers we have
which had previous estimates of um sort
of 60 000 pounds of sort of capital
maintenance per site per year which
would give us sort of a 900 000 pound
cost over a five-year period although we
do have a Leisure Reserve 500 000 in it
um we've looked at electrical vehicles
um in the past so just for the Vans we
had an estimate of an extra sort of 300
000 just for our smaller Vans going to
Electric
um there's also obviously will be some
new PEDs in the next five years which
will be required but we don't know what
they will be at this point there's also
the linear defense
project which is we're working with the
environment agency on and also inflation
going forwards as well
so with all that under consideration
Project's under a little bit of pressure
but we still do have even with some of
those
we still have a small Surplus at the
moment next slide please Tom
um and as you'll all be aware we
um the Abdul clean Maritime Innovation
Center we've been awarded a 15.6 million
pound of grant funding for this so as a
council we'll provide the site
down at middle dunk we will require some
borrowing to meet the total cost of the
project
um project will be designed to be cost
neutral so the any additional borrowing
is planned to be funded from revenue
that the site generates and we will at
some point in the future be submitting a
PID
um to get this formally added into the
capital program
next slide please Tom
um so that brings me to the end really
so that's where we ask for members to
recommend to full Council that the
capital tool program is updated to
include selly house Sully house module
units and the hopperstone conversion
so I'm happy to take any questions
thank you just to check the the modular
units there was grant funding for that
wasn't there and that's why we were
under pressure to get a decision so
that's what that's what the figure up
there is what we've got to put in over
and above the grant funding I think it
will include the grant funding that will
include that will be the total cost
right so but there is some Grant to go
with it yeah okay thank you
you mentioned where when you're a
defense um explained I don't know what
that is
if I'm saying anything wrong will make
me wish to add
um so the the end of Westwood Hall
um there's significant uh defense
defenses all along the front across the
Promenade across that end not not uh the
Pebble Ridge obviously over the the last
number of years that's been failing so
we've done a number of times remedial
works and I'm just trying to think of
the time time it was the year before
last then some more substantive Works
were were put in place
um at Cost but they were only temporary
Works whilst the environment agency
through its programs and money from
central government without a developing
a more substantial to scheme what we
don't know is whether the environment
agency and the government will fully
fund that or whether there will be an
expectation that torrage in some way has
to put some resources towards it and
that's what Peter was alluding to we
because we don't know it's a risk but we
know there's a project underway
thank you
would you like to say anything
I think Steve
is that as a council we have been
lobbying our MP
to Lobby the environmental agency
to expedite matters to make sure that
we've got things in place there are
plans uh being drawn up to actually
replace the temporary works so
everything is being progressed
any questions
do we all agree
ment
okay
we're going to
important
about the senses
thank you
opponent
yeah
yeah I'm in control thank you sorry
thank you very much
um I'm just going to run through um some
uh census results for you
um
a little bit of a brief recap so census
day was the 21st of March 21 we have a
90 or we the country I don't know 97
response rate of which 88.9 responded
online and that was a record that's the
most ever
um
for England and Wales there was a
population of just under 60 million
and that was a growth of about 3.5
million so uh 6.3 so I went through a
bit of the introduction
um with you previously
um just some top level info but since
then we've had this information
released by the census so I'll run
through some with you now so this is
another recap so for storage
we had a 6.7
increase up to 68 100.
this um graph I did share with you last
time which shows kind of the age split
um with the one I just circled there
showing kind of our aging population
um what I we mentioned before they're
about the
um
I wanted to say the brain drain but
um the uh kind of the working age
leaving the area and another one that
I've highlighted there now or the 50s
the over the 50 in between 50s and 60s
you'll notice that the government are
making a real big play or trying to get
the um over 50s back into the market and
you'll see actually we had a really big
increase in that
for the census so that that is something
to bear in mind
I suppose the key bit here is we had a
0.6 decrease of people aged 15 to 64. so
that's that shows kind of you know the
people leaving and an increase of 1.6 of
children under the age of 15. so again
the Aging population it's quite a
powerful
um graph this one and you'll see how
that compares to the left-hand side
which is the um in English
average so you'll see that there I will
share all these slides with you after so
you can have a little bit of time to
look at it so this this graph I want to
show you because a lot of these are
going to be like this today
um so this is the medium
age as as I said just now about um uh
you know in the 50s so in 2011 the
median age for toriage was 47. that's
increased by four years up to 51. now I
just want to show you the chart on the
bottom
that shows you where we sit
nationally so the lowest one there on in
the green is 30 and the highest is 54.
so that's at 51 we're really we're on
the top end of that scale and you'll
also see the the coloring on the on the
map showing our neighbors in the
southwestern now that is colored the
darker where we are is the higher bit
and and the lighter so there'll be a lot
of these slides as I go through just
have a quick look at the chart of the
bottom it will show you where we sit
nationally and it's a really good kind
of indicator of kind of the extremes
that we do and if it's in the middle
then that shows that you know we are
kind of on average so again it shows
that we are an aging population
so labor market traveled to work
so what this one shows is basically the
national figures
um and the top five
um they're nationally
um and kind of the the uh
employers retail Education Health
construction and public admin and
defense
it shows the movers and the biggest
increase in movers was in the computer
industry that moved up from 14th to 8th
and the biggest decrease was in the
financial services so that went down
from 10 to 13th
how that compares you won't be able to
see that with figures on there but when
you get your own ones how that compares
with storage well Health and Social care
our biggest employer wholesale retail
repair of Motor Vehicles the second
construction then education and
Manufacturing
um I do get asked about agriculture
that's at the top there that's just not
in the top five that's seven point one
percent of our
um you know kind of a lecture
so again those figures show
um and you'll have time to look at these
so
um percentage of those age 16s and over
that economically active
so that is
um
52.2 percent which is down 3.5 from 2011
when it was 55.8 percent
and again those colors you'll see the
colors there
um nationally
so economically inactive uh 45.4 percent
as you look at it very dark again in the
top 20 percent
um as you'll see where we are compared
um nationally
um again look at retired 32 percent
High
um in the in the top 20 again
um with the dark colors
Unemployment uh 2.4 so kind of on the
lower end of the scale now so that's an
interesting stat
[Music]
um
so of those uh people who are unemployed
not worked in
um over 16 but not worked
um
10 did work in the last 12 months so
again on the lower end of the scale so
10 had worked in those last 10 percent
um in the last 12 months
um
74 of those not in employment
had not worked in the last 12 months and
that's a high percentage looking at that
compared to nationally so that's another
interesting stat
um and then never worked 15.6
um lower end of the scale lower lowest
20 as well
um number of hours people have worked
part-time 15 hours or less again very
high 12.8 on that high scale top 20. so
showing that you know we we have got a
high proportion of part-time workers
um once again 16 to 30 so still
part-time but 16 to 30
24.4 the the highest in the country was
25.2 so again top end of the that scale
for you
um of part-time workers
full time so that's 38 to 48 hours
so now we're on the lower end of the
scale at 49 with the lowest nationally
being 47.7 so you can see those stats
show that we have got a very high
proportion of part-time
and then full time 48 49 hours or more
we're kind of the middle at 13.8 percent
so it shows you giving you a little
picture as we go through them so what
kind of jobs do they do
so managers director of senior officials
um in the in the second uh 20 there
um professional
occupations again in the lower end 12.6
percent
um associate professional technical
um
um so we're kind of coming down the
scale of how how they rate them as in
senior Authority so again Lower 9.6
percent
um
so the ad name and secretary occupations
8.4 percent kind of middle of the road
um interesting one here I thought skill
trades 18.8 percent
the highest Nash you know right at the
top end of the scale nationally the top
one is 19.8 so we are right up the top
showing what you know the skilled trades
uh a big
um proportion of um our employment in
this area
um similarly caring and the Leisure
another service occupations that's in
the top 20 as well at 12.4 percent
uh sales seven point eight percent
middle of the road
um 7.4 process planned to machine
operatives
um and the elementary kind of the kind
of um like um the lowest lower end of
the scale of the employment again at 11
right at the middle of the road
um this isn't from a census but I
thought it would be interesting bearing
in mind the other stuff we saw on the
kind of the skills trade so this is from
the latest ones I could find for Nomes
in June 22 self-employed so torrage 18.2
percent that's against uh Southwest
average of 11.1 percent and uh National
yeah nationally at 9.2 percent so again
kind of quite an interesting stat there
just very quickly travel to work less
than 10
kilometers 27 percent and over the lower
end of the scale uh however 10
kilometers to 30 were quite a bigger
um
traveling uh distance for for our
residents and maximum top 20 nationally
as well so that's at 22.5 percent
um and they're more than 30
5.9 and that's kind of middle of the
road
um mainly working from home that's 25.9
percent
um
and that is kind of the lower end of the
scale I guess a lot of this you've got
to remember it was during the pandemic
they did ask people to say what their
normal was but they have put kind of
caveats on the results to say that they
have been
um
affected by the pandemic so some of
those just got to kind of bear that in
mind
the trouble to work uh meth method so
driving
on 39.1 percent passenger Carl Van 3.9
bus minibus uh two percent
yeah that was quite a low one in fact
when I compared to North Devon North
Devon's traveled by bike was higher than
ours but they're all on the bit that you
can't read at the moment so they'll come
round
um education so we're looking at kind of
what what uh qualifications our
residents have uh so no qualifications
at all so that's 18.8 percent looking at
where that sits it's kind of middle of
the low for nationally
um so what this shows is the highest at
the highest the personnel has is their
level one so that's kind of the level
one entry-level qualification so that's
a low qualification and as we go through
though the qualifications gets higher so
just share that in mind so
11.5 of the um residents have a highest
level of a level one qualification and
that's in the top 20 of the country so
that's a low level really of quality but
it'll I'll show you a little bit more
now so so level two
um and on there which you can't read
says what the level two is so five gcses
or more and a few other examples but
that'll be on there when when you see
again
we are high as that compared nationally
so then we look at the apprentices
that's high as well so that's 7.3 and
then again we're on the top 20
um when we're compared nationally
um level three so this is two or more a
levels and
um higher School certificates Etc
Advanced diploma so again it'll explain
it probably middle of the road there at
17.6 percent
um level four so this is degree or
higher
um and this is 26.2 percent and I guess
that's kind of quite low in comparison
to to the national uh figure so that's
uh the lowest there nationally would be
18.2 so we're in the lowest 20 for that
one
and then this um uh vocational
um qualification work related
qualification at 2.8 and that's kind of
middle of the road on that one
so just looking at the household
composition
one person age 66 and over
we are 16.3 and we're in the top 20
there nationally when you compare it so
we've got again that shows going back to
the Aging population but this also shows
that it's one person kind of living on
their own as well is a High
um
a proportion single families all age 66
and over again we're looking at a high
14.6 percent you know moving to the top
top of the scale there for for
nationally
um
the single-family households of a
married or civil with no children that's
high as well at 14.1 percent
um that's in the top 20 percent just
very briefly looking at deprivation I I
put this up because they don't do
depresions similarly to how others do it
so
um they say there
their stats will decide whether they're
deprived in one area no areas one area
two areas two areas or four and this is
how they measure it
um so I have Services classified as
deprived in education if one
um if no one has at least level two
education and no one age 16 to 18 is a
full-time student
um
employment
is if any member not a full-time student
is either unemployed or disabled
mention if any member is disabled and
then the housing side is the house of
accommodation is overcrowded in a shared
dwelling there
how they do it
it's quite different to how other
measures happen
so just send me a few slides on this one
but it's not deprived in any one
is 46.1 percent
but that means 53.9
of the residents fire department at
least one area
so
this shows 39 35.9 I decided in one of
those areas again which is quite High
naturally when you look at it
um 14
um
14 in
two Dimensions so thank you and then
that's kind of middle of the road for
when you compare nationally
um in three dimensions it's three
percent and that was starting to Edge to
the lower end of the scale and
um in all four dimensions it's point two
percent again that's probably middle of
the road there will be some more stats
and some more detail and that
um later when they start getting into
the nitty-gritty of it so this is still
quite top um
you
um UK Armed Forces those that are
previously served kind of the veterans
side of stuff so that where we stand
there
um 4.5 regular 0.9 as a reserve and 0.2
percent
um
uh in both
passports held interestingly and I think
Tom might have found this interesting
when we're talking about
um having
um
photo ID
I thought it's just quite an interesting
one because we're 22.5 like close to the
top end of the um kind of national
um start there and I I didn't come put
my finger on it but I thought I was an
interesting man
uh yeah
yes that's it yes
um
so there are a few health stats now just
a few of them I'll quickly run through
um and that's just how they've done it
and there's some um
so this 7.8
um
um of saying that
um they're disabled with uh limited
um day-to-day activities limited a lot
so it's kind of middle of the road for
um nationally
um day-to-day activities limited a
little so that's 11.4 percent and again
that shows edging higher towards
um the national average
not disabled under the equality act 80.7
um yeah kind of towards the lower end
just not into that generally very good
health so we're middle 48 percent
uh github's 33.7
Fair house 13.2 and all of these have
been kind of middle of the road when
compared nationally bad Health 4.1
percent
very bad Health 1.1 yeah sorry
no call was just below us people of
torrage yeah and you would see
cornwall's a bit darker so that they
would be higher than us
um
no one paid care
90.4 percent kind of middle of the road
there
um 19 or hours or less per week uh 4.7
just aging up to the higher end
20 to 49 hours of unpaid care uh 1.9
percent
um 50 hours of all week kind of three
three percent again looking at
nationally about average
um that's a whistle stopped tour of the
slides
um they are going to start doing some
multivariant data and Analysis so that's
when they'll start getting into the
nitty-gritty so once that happens I'll
be able to share some more with you I've
got uh somebody on my team currently
working on some Ward profiles which will
be ready for the next election so we're
working on that and there are a few
links there that when we share it with
you if you want to have a look for
yourself they're there
we can share a slides with the committee
chair
sorry about that happy to answer any
questions
well I'm probably going to make myself
look really stupid now but because I
probably misunderstood something
completely but
um but for we were quite high for
economically inactive
but reasonably low for unemployment so
is that saying unless I misunderstood it
is that saying that because a lot of
people who are economically inactive
aren't actually unemployed yeah but it's
over there yes what that can mean is
that they're not actively looking for a
job or they can't actually have a job so
it could be because of illness it could
be because they're caring it could be
for anything so the unemployment side of
it is kind of that they
um you're either looking for a job
um or they're capable of having a job
within a period of time so they're
officially registering as unemployed yes
so we're quite low on that one
nationally yeah but yeah okay thank you
yeah left it
nope okay
um John you you said all the profiles
will be ready for the next election
which in action
character is it the world's coming up
yes
on our on our website and already we're
being updated now with a lot of this
information and yeah their aim is for to
be ready for May
okay
to the outside like there's hard drives
the issue that medical participating up
to date this
Independence on and they everybody will
get a new uh wall Amendment list within
the next few weeks before you've heard
about that is that is that for the
register of electors rather than the
yeah
does a chair
right
laughs
all right
okay that's that's done that was good uh
will there be anything to come back to
the next meeting on this oh well we'll
see what comes out with the um yeah when
you start looking
um kind of forward plans and stuff if
there's yeah the subject matter then I
can dig deeper but I mean I mean the
next one the next thing is
yeah yeah yeah qpr3
it depends when they're ready
foreign
I think
right our next meeting our next meeting
I had moved it to the 16th
of March because one
it was at this
um I don't really want us to be
discussed
on that on that meeting there will be
the calling for
good
thank you
I must still concentration I'm thinking
about
things so yeah so it will be on the 16th
right at 10 o'clock
I'm sorry all right
but you will love him
yes
okay exclusion of public you can go
again
um
that's it meeting finished at
um okay